F boy Island uh what season is it on now
well as you know we're kind of in
between like waiting for a pickup I'm a
big fan oh thank you I loved the show oh
my God you guys would have both been
good on that show you would be good now
I'm sure you're in relationship what
does that mean just like you're
watchable you're handsome it's kind of
like we're both nice guys I don't know
you appear to be you know but that you
don't know so you'd be really good if
you like get it like so yeah it's the
premise of the show if you don't know
three girls are looking for love and
then there's 30 guys and 15 are
um nice guys and 15 are F boys but they
all look like f boys and it's um yeah
it's fun remember when it's the best
thing I've ever done when I first saw
the trailer and it was like okay what is
like what the it just seemed like
another dating show that didn't really
understand itself but it's like super
self-aware yes like it makes fun of
itself a lot and yeah I got got on the
first season I took it too seriously
same this show is [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
cringe and that's oh wait it's a bit
yeah and the first season it was Towing
that line of like we weren't we weren't
going as hard on wink wink like we're in
on the joke too so I think second season
is when we really were like let's have a
lot of fun with this and make fun of
this as much as possible and yeah um
yeah a lot of the show itself like it
came with the name f boy Island when it
landed in front of me like I gotta I
kind of told my agents I want to get
into the reality space because it's like
the only TV I watched yet I'm
auditioning for these like roles on
scripted stuff I don't even like
scripted TV and so I was like I want to
do reality I don't know how and then um
they sent me a bunch of shows that were
like looking for hosts and I saw F boy
Island I was like that's gotta be funny
like that's that it already has a sense
of humor in the title that can't be a
serious show I mean it reminded me of 30
Rock they had a fake show called MILF
Island and it was like that's what it
reminded me of and so I was like
um I don't realize that yeah by the way
that is actually being made I'm pretty
sure it's not called MILF Island but my
friend just like posted on close story
about how he's his close friend's story
about how he's getting cast for a show
about young guys dating older women
yeah young gravy the host I mean yeah I
know it does sound like a great I would
love to be on that show so
um I uh sign me up no I am very happily
in a relationship but uh but when does
this air
um
no so um no but when it came like they
the guy that created Elon Gail he's he
worked at The Bachelor and you know
Bachelorette first like 20 years and
then he started producing these other
reality shows and he called me and was
like I think he'd be good for this and I
was like please God yes and it was the
first time in my you know at this point
18-year career that I'd ever wanted
something so badly and the network
wanted me just as much where it was like
Mutual it always I don't know my
relationships are always felt like that
my nothing's ever felt Mutual in my
goddamn life like I've always been
chasing something that doesn't want me
and it was the first time I was like oh
they want me too and a lot of people
through their name into to be the host
of it because it's a great role it's
comedic and
um and you get to live in paradise and
just hang out it's so [ __ ] easy how
many weeks are you there dude it's the
it's it's like five to six weeks like
maybe like eight eight the first season
because we had to quarantine for two
weeks when we got there and it was two
it was 2021 and America was still very
much mass land and it was like you know
early 2021 and we go to the Cayman
Islands and they have no covid on their
Island so we get in there's people in
hazmat suits greeting us we go instantly
into a bubble and we stay in our um
hotels for two weeks and then when we
got out no masks and so it was like
everyone's ready to [ __ ] like the crew
the cat like everyone everyone
some [ __ ] wild it was so much fun so
anyone in the crew bone each other
I don't know I don't know yeah I thought
that was like a yes of course they did
yeah
so much of that going on you find out
afterwards that's what I mean yeah but
then you find out later and you're like
oh my God those sorry I should have
phrased that like did two core people on
set [ __ ] and everyone kind of knew like
yeah so the director just [ __ ] the uh
first assistant camera and right it's on
set in front of everyone yeah
and uh now it's awkward
um I think that that most of that stuff
came out after the fact that everyone
was kind of blowing like
oh okay which you know I whenever I'm on
a set of more he's like oh my God this
would be so fun to have a set set man
sir what do they call them uh showmans
that makes more sense
show man yeah where you're like and and
that's why I would never date an actor
because if you get if you're a hot guy
and you get paired with some hot girl
and you go to Paris for like eight weeks
to shoot something and you're doing
scenes where you're like making out and
falling in love it's so impossible not
to catch feelings I mean cheating is one
thing and people should have enough
integrity but they're gonna catch
feelings regardless you're too close
you're involved in this thing that you
know you're in this bubble no one else
knows about you feel like it's almost
like trauma bonding and so you know I'm
not surprised Angelina Jolie seduced
Brad Pitt like those kinds of things
happen I would be I'd be Jada Pinkett
Smith I heard on the set of
um
whatever Will Smith did with Margot
Robbie she would like be in the room
during their sex scenes oh wow just like
hang out at set that day wow I'd
probably do that too no I actually I
wouldn't I'm not like a jealous person
I'd be like go try to get Margot Robbie
tell me about it like I'd really be like
I'm proud of you I saw her at John and
Vinnie's I saw a guy try his damnedest
to make an introduction it was kind of
funny oh my God what did he do she was
picking up food and you know God bless
her she rolled in there solo she just
had a car waiting out front but she
hopped out the car by herself she all
like Hood up no it was just her she just
it's stunning she just walked a good
like Margot [ __ ] she walked a good like
30 feet on her own which I thought was
[ __ ] wow yeah and then she walks in
the restaurant and just said hi for Mago
and they go get the food and some guy's
like hey
I'm already like so comfortable he's
like John we we both know and he like
says a random name and she's like I
don't I don't know a Patrick he's like
no yeah you do and he's really trying to
make it happen oh yeah that's so
uncomfortable oh yo I love Wolf of Wall
Street by the way yeah that's my
favorite film yeah yeah yeah I feel like
that's okay like I don't know how do you
guys feel about when you see celebrities
like it's someone who really matters to
you or like do you do you get a picture
what do you do and like how do you deal
with it with fans like what's your best
what's the best approach people hit us
up for pictures it's fine I don't say no
every time yeah
yeah yeah he'd win the show yeah I said
maybe yeah that's what I said usually
um I'm fine with it I I get
uncomfortable because sometimes some
people are a bit rude to the people
around them like these three guys like
ran into me to an airport and I thought
that was cool like fine but um
then they wanted a picture but none of
them wanted to hold it so he turns to a
guy who's eating and he's like yo can
you take this pick and the guy that's
the worst the guy I was like hey man
like I but the guy jumped in for him
he's like I'm [ __ ] eating bro and the
guy's like oh and his friend's like dude
just take a selfie just took a selfie
when they jammed the phone in my
fiance's face and they go hey can you
take this yeah that's awesome no please
either yeah yeah no please they look and
they're like can we get a photo and I'm
like sure and they're like cool here
yeah you're just jamming in her and I'm
like it happens [ __ ] respect so
[ __ ] off I love that you guys are
saying this too because I felt like
maybe I I'm crazy for noticing this but
I do meet and greets and I have a guy
that is there to take pictures and
they'll like they'll be like what is
like you you didn't even use the right
lens like they'll yell at him about it
I'm like he's not getting paid he's
getting paid
he's not getting paid well okay for that
no it's so real he is disabled okay
that's why it's at a low angle I'm sorry
he can't get your perfect angle and I
shot his [ __ ] eyes out so just be
glad that he was able to click the phone
at all oh my God
yeah people are just like here and then
they get mad about like and then they
get mad at you and they're like it's
blurry we need to do it again it's like
you got one shot and just do selfies I
think I love taking pictures with people
but I know like I like taking pictures
with celebrities I want them some I was
on the with on the set with the
Backstreet Boys yesterday and I was like
oh my God I want a picture so bad but I
I didn't because I didn't have my phone
on me because we were shooting the scene
and when it wrapped it was like I would
have had to get it and stuff so I got
other people's pictures of the scene but
what I think the best protocol what I
would do is have your camera ready
before you ask have it already open to
like a selfie like it's shooting right
and then go would you mind if we had a
selfie and then just boom click it's
fast instead of like you go I love you
so much and you're pulling up the apps
and you go oh my god this is my dog oh
my gosh and like oh okay why is this not
working and you have to like go through
their whole you know I think it's just a
test operating system social media has
just like ruined everything thing yeah
like there's no like etiquette anymore
there's no I'm not begging on people
that are fans of other I probably do the
same thing just the parasocial
relationships yeah you're just used to
feeling like you actually know these
people so you see them in public yes and
you're like oh [ __ ] yeah here let's get
a pig dude let's get a pig yes I'm in
the middle of a meal there's something
really nice about the fact that
especially podcasting there people feel
closer to you because you're in their
ear it's like you're like whispering to
them like how often as humans before
media did we ever have someone like in
our ear intimately it'd be like a lover
and so people are conditioned to think
that they have these really intimate
relationships with you which is so great
because it makes for just making such
great fans that know you and care about
you and will be lifelong fans but at the
same time they do have that familiarity
that they can like mistreat you but you
know where that kind of like is kind of
it's rare that's like one a hundred yeah
yeah that's true not everyone does I
feel like I feel like we're being like
spoiled right now no no no most people
are so awesome yeah yeah and spoiled to
have people like care about us enough to
even want to [ __ ] picture yeah and if
you ask me for a picture I will say no
yeah
yes don't do the phone jamming thing no
I hate that picture well I get mad when
people are like I saw you at the gym but
I didn't want to bother you I'm like
this is why I do this I want to be I
want people to go yeah
it's awesome please bother me I love it
you know what I love dude is um
recently I've had a lot of people come
up it'll be like it'd just be like
random dudes and they'll be like yo
yeah and they just walk away yeah I'm
like oh that was sick yes yes
because I like that because I'm like oh
we're boys